metro police have made an arrest in the
death of a female cyclist and another
man police say 22 year old rodrigo cruz
was the driver of a van involved in this
crime 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond
has the latest on the case spray paint
marks up hollywood boulevard near sahara
indicating the aftermath of a deadly
attack against a bicyclist
that is terrible you know something like
that someone like just me you know go
out there and you think you're going to
go
exercise and you know and these things
like this happen
christina perez lives nearby and likes
to jog around the neighborhood
but is now thankful for her late start
sunday morning
that could have been me an arrest report
reveals what officers call
a senseless act police say rodrigo cruz
was driving a van with
two people while speeding between 50 and
60 miles per hour
he drove closely to a cyclist identified
as 56-year-old michelle weissman
police say the passenger was sitting on
the car's window ledge
leaning out and pushed weissman to the
ground the momentum
also made the passenger fall out of the
van skid 150 feet and hit his head on a
street light
weissman and the passenger died i think
the entire
cycling community as well as just the
general public
must is outraged and shocked that
somebody could have this kind of
behavior
police arrested cruz and he made his
first court appearance
he's charged with violating parole open
murder and
not stopping i never seen anything like
that happen around
the neighborhood surprising moments
making perez more cautious before she
exercises
kristen drummond 8 news now
crews scheduled to be back in court on
wednesday